Crowd: Good morning John, it's Friday!
Hank: Good morning John, today is my first
day off, in like four weeks. The universe
kept conspiring to prevent me from getting
a full night's sleep, and yesterday, I realized
that if it did it one more time, I would destroy
it. The entire universe, I would set it to
flame, and watch it burn. So, I slept. Lucky
for you.
I'm on tour with a rock and roll band right
now, which is really weird. I've been to a
lot of shows in my life, and I will be honest,
never in my life have I not felt anxious before
a show, whether I'm there as a performer,
or just as someone watching the show. The
institution of the show seems to have a lot
of cultural knowledge associated with it and
it also kind of seems like just sort of the
thing like very cool people do. I am not a
very cool person! So I always felt like there's
just a lot of stuff I don't know, and I'm
not sure if I'm doing the right things ever.
It almost seems like part of the coolness
of it is hiding all those do's and don't's
from "normal people" so that you can know
when they're not cool, and that is a thing
I hate.
So on my shows, I've been asking the audience
what is some of the institutional knowledge
of concerts that you think should be shared
with the world, and I've been collecting that
information and now I'm going to share it
with you!
Crowd member: Wear deodorant!
Crowd: *laughs*
Hank: Number one. Bring earplugs! Because
sometimes it is dangerously loud, sometimes
it's not, but you never know!
Number two. You can go by yourself. It's nice
to bring people along with you but you can
also have an amazing time alone.
Three. Make sure you have enough charge on
your cellphone to get you through the night.
Four. You never know how hot it's going to
be, so hydrate and bring layers.
Five. Buy merch on the way in because when
you're leaving, it will a mess and the line
will be a million miles long.
Six. Dance, clap, singing along, every audience
is different and what happens out there affects
what goes on on the stage.
Seven. If you want to be at the front, get
there early. Do not push your way to the front
because you are moving past the people who
got there early so that they could be at the
front. And that's rude.
Eight. As far as I can tell, there's no schedule.
I don't even know when I'm going on as a performer;
it's up to the venue. Generally, doors will
open about an hour before the show actually
starts, and the main act will be on for at
least two hours after the doors open.
Some venues like to leave like thirty minutes
between every single act so that people have
time to buy more drinks (which is how they
make a lot of their money), but none of this
has anything to do with performers. I would
assume that you're not going to be going home
until at least three hours after the doors
open, and maybe more than four.
Nine. Wear comfortable shoes.
Ten. If you ask, you'll probably get an encore.
Eleven. Interact with strangers. Chances are
you're into some of the same things since
you're obviously into the same music. People
are usually pretty nice, chances are they're
as uncomfortable as you are. Like I am right
now.
Thirteen. Moshpits are surprisingly safe;
stage diving is surprisingly dangerous. You
don't want anybody to jump on your head. If
you don't want to be in a moshpit, just leave
the moshpit area. If you do, make sure your
shoes are on tight and your glasses ...they're
all loose items necessary precautions taken,
etcetera.
Twelve. If you feel unsafe or uncomfortable
let the people around you know or let the
venue staff know and they will help you.
And finally, number thirteen. This was shouted
out at my Portland show, and I couldn't hear
the person who shouted it so I asked the people
around that person to shout it at me simultaneously,
and the thing that got shouted at me by dozens
of people was " DON'T WORRY ABOUT LOOKING
COOL!" and it was a glorious moment.
I wish I could start every day with a group
of people shouting that at me. It would be
nice for all of us I think. It would be wonderful
if we could all get this through out thick
skulls, but of course we can't and so we have
to continue repeating it to each other. But
don't worry about looking cool; do you, because
you are fantastic.
I had the whole audience shout it at me again,
and then I had them shout it at each other,
because I think that's the most important
advice when it comes to going to concerts.
It's not about looking cool; it's about being
excited about something together with other
people who are also excited about it.
It has been really, really, really amazingly
fantastic to a part of that for people.
So thanks to everone who've been coming out
to the shows; we've been having a really great
time.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.